i i i don't eat a lot of japanese
chocolate bars because i noticed that in
japan
i feel like uh
they just make chocolate bars that taste
good and then they worry about what's in
it after because like every single
chocolate bar you look at the packaging
like oh my jesus christ when you read
the like the nutritional information
yeah yeah it's like they'll have like 50
grams of sugar or something in it
we could play about coke cans japan's
dude what what
i don't know it's just me personally i i
i it's how often do you eat black
fondant no i don't but okay in my mind
right i don't care about like a lot of
the time if i want to [ __ ] talk about
i don't care about the calorie count but
sometimes you're in that mood i'm like i
want chocolate but i also want to not
kill myself so and is this thing tasting
is this thing going to taste so good
that it's worth putting this in my body
right so it's kind of like a toss up
yeah and a lot of the time in japan
weirdly there's just a lot of
chocolate balls of snacks that are just
absolutely rammed with like carbs and
sugars like way more than normal stuff
oh yeah i don't know if you've noticed
this no no you should you should pick
them up have a look and just compare
them to some chocolates that we have or
other american ones but they're pretty
put other god knows what chemicals i
mean
i rarely eat sweets so yeah i just don't
[ __ ] with it yeah i should give me a
[ __ ] sandwich
[Music]
like if i'm hungry i'll just eat a
sandwich no for some reason like for me
i rarely eat chocolate bars because if i
want something sweet i want like a nice
like a rich they're a premium one like a
rich cake or really nice ice cream or
something something that's gonna like
you know fill that uh feel that desire
for me but that's why i mean i mean
that's why i rarely eat desserts i think
because i rarely get into the mood to
eat something sweet well we had this
conversation like a couple weeks ago but
yeah yeah what's what's your favorite
chocolate bar
it will do we have to do like a
chocolate bar teal okay i'm gonna be
honest i'm saying this right now i know
it's not chocolate but i like white
chocolate the most and i know it's awful
for you as well it tastes so good though
really yeah white chocolate is probably
my least favorite [ __ ]
it's just pure sugar like at least
chocolate has something in it yeah white
chocolate is just sugar it's nothing
it's not even chocolate i like the cocoa
i like that i think i think dark
chocolate is my favorite i'm gonna go
milk chocolate it's just just to round
things off can i have a teeth oh can i
have like a hot no no if you were to
just have it by itself
are you talking about brands are you
just talking about white dark or well i
mean brands or whatever because it like
it's hard to choose a brand because i
don't think it's fair to like compare
toblerone yay or nay yay
that's that's that's yeah
yeah yeah i mean i don't think it's fair
to compare say dairy milk to lindor or
ferrero russia
are we just talking about the bare bones
five guys to internet you know it's just
not not fair they're a different price
cap
we do that
why are you oh we did that we're guilty
save this for the america tour i don't
really feel like arguing about burgers
i'm not i've got chocolate on the
mountain now do you still want to
continue the chocolate debate yeah yeah
yeah i mean i just uh joey asked the
question i have a loaded topic next
after the chocolate
i am not ready but uh i'll be dragging
this chocolate conversation as much as
possible
honestly one of my favorites is yeah i
mean dairy milk i've grown an
appreciation student of dairy milk after
moving out of england yeah i think
british chocolates are actually really
really [ __ ] good when you take one
bite of hershey's you're like oh
oh this is disgusting it kind of yeah
it's just horrible i don't know why chop
like hershey's to me
always it it kind of tastes like farts i
don't know why like it it tastes
gasoline i think it had to do with uh
like world war two right so i think
world war ii yeah when
obviously those were there rationing
everything i think
i think the uk and some other european
countries just decided to just make less
chocolate because they were like yeah
we're not gonna make that and whereas i
think america wanted to give a lot of
the troops chocolate i could be wrong
you might want to can you fact-check
this
can you double check that but it's
something along those lines where they
wanted to keep giving chocolates people
because you know it's a little good
morale booster so they made chocolate
that had a lot less chocolate
a lot less milk and a lot
because the you know it takes a lot of
milk and a lot less cocoa cocoa cocoa
cacao
um
and so they ended up making this kind of
like weird sugary [ __ ] mess
and uh yeah and then they were making it
all throughout the war hershey's so yeah
so people are still eating hershey's and
they make fun of british people for
eating war ration like food
[ __ ] in america still eating
war rations dude and it's like their
favorite chocolate bar it just doesn't
taste good it doesn't it doesn't taste
like chocolate no and it's so obvious
that if you eat any chocolate from
europe and then you go to america and
you have american chocolate you're like
this isn't chocolate what is this this
is like if an alien sore chocolate
tasted it was like i will replicate this
and formulate well i think even asian
chocolates aren't that good like the
bare bones basic chocolate bars you kind
of could get good chocolate here yeah
but if you're just talking about here's
the some of the cheapest options you can
[ __ ] get a lot of asian chocolates
are just missing that like the weight
the the heaviness that you get in
european chocolates i feel like of like
a frodo bar is like better than pretty
much
hold up frodo is it fro is it right
i'm sorry
i believe
i believe he's from waterloo
hey fredo can you make a can you make a
bar that's just shapely frodo from lord
of the rings
myself
i'm more of a gimli guy
get the gang
yeah like freddo bars are like the
better than basically any kind of cheap
chocolate you can get in asia i think
yeah
yeah i based that on japan and thailand
yeah that's the reason i don't get
chocolate bars here because there's
nothing that really feels that
like that makes me get like feels that
satisfaction for me i think it's just a
culture thing right like they just don't
have a history and a big culture of
making chocolate as long as like say
europe yeah yeah i mean they they have a
they obviously made chocolate but you
know yeah because a lot japan has a lot
of its own type of sweets right
give us some knowledge yeah so
um for the american
soldiers during world war two because it
would give them
yeah cool so yeah i was kind of right
yeah yes nice
i was wow wrong i don't know okay i
might have been wrong on the makeup of
what goes into hershey's but i'm pretty
sure it's like less chocolate did you
learn that from a johnny harris video
vox
thank you vox
all right what was your [ __ ]
pre-loaded
argument
yeah sure all right okay
also before we leave the chocolate
debate and sweets japan's sweets kind of
lame not gonna lie just saying
yeah it depends do you want beans
[Laughter]
this japanese sweets
do you want beans is this your first day
in japan
you want peas
if you want beans
japan desserts like do you want beans
beans paste no it's like there's there's
more variety than just [ __ ] chocos i
know you i know you you want one type of
dessert and it's like either [ __ ] ice
cream or chocolate yeah yeah yeah you're
like anything else anything else
disgusting i cannot imagine any cakes
cakes are good who the [ __ ] eats beans
for dessert ew disgusting
i can't imagine why any other culture
would want to eat anything else that's
sweet other than
chocolate and ice cream unfathomable we
should start colonizing these places
show them what a real dessert
okay